white hats hackers who are they hacking
is a term usually associated with crime
data leaks and stolen information
however there are ethical hackers out
there who are called White hats the term
white hat comes from old westerns where
the good guys usually wore white hats
while the bad guys wore black ones since
the 1970s companies all over the world
have been hiring white hats who
deliberately tried to hack into computer
systems using the same methods that the
bad guys use they even tried to trick
their fellow co-workers into clicking on
maliciously
coined by John Patrick from IBM the term
ethical hacking has only been around
since 1995. since then this has become a
legitimate career nowadays white hats
can become certified ethical hackers and
there are competitions worldwide where
contestants can win huge prizes like
this video if you found it interesting